oh hi oh hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to the visitor
now this is the first v5 right oculus
vive horror game that I played I don't
know if it's the breast but it's the
first one that I found and I need to pay
attention to flickering lights
so apparently oh okay I was already a
little spooky
oh hello hi Oh God oh hello okay so
apparently there's no controller
there's no controller support needed is
that you mother
are you come to tuck me in tonight if
that was even words in a sentence
okay so supposedly I just sit here like
the good little boy that I am in my
little bed even though it's kind of a
sprawled out thrown it's very delightful
and I got a picture of a on the dad oh
I'm not a child why did I always default
to me being a little boy
that's alright says something about my
personality and why do I have a
grandfather clock in my room why do I
sleep with the doors both open this is
seems brutal
okay that is that is a very bizarre
painting to have above my bed or not
above my bed but looking above my bed oh
okay and that's another odd painting to
have in my room staring at me oh hi how
are you doing are you friendly probably
not
oh why honey is that you darling dear oh
my lovely wife come to tuck me in I like
to roleplay dhama I'm one of those
adults that adult baby died aw come on
no hey I'm good this time I'm good as a
bad say
baby diaper fetishists not that I'm well
opposed to anybody liking what the asker
whatever I'm in a horror game right now
I'm not talking about that
okay oh oh good I needed a little more
draft here is that another door oh this
is just a lightful Oh what am I doing
here
hi
okay I was cool nothing happened but you
know I'm still here and alive and
talking oh [ __ ] okay what's up ah [ __ ]
now those flickering outside of matter
um now it's flickering inside of my room
though
come on now oh you're gonna go with the
horror movie cliche well how about a
little bit of this I mean you can't see
it in the game but I'm doing it hard
that's what I thought
sir bad [ __ ] you you're better with a
huh don't mind my prepubescent cracking
voice I'm very brave and manly ah [ __ ]
you see see the way I shouted that was
in a brave and manly way it scared them
so much that they ran away and that's
the point that I'm trying to make here
okay that's good midnight the perfect
time for me to beat the [ __ ] out of the
ghosts in my house and also bury all the
repressed memories of my probably dead
child and dead wife great Knight to f4
okay chess I go off or you know that's
gonna check make me oh god okay
all right then wow the whole lot of
nothing mr. brave man overall god it's
getting closer
what do you say to me why I wasn't gonna
I didn't plan on it
Bob what's up back okay [ __ ] you
what does suck okay hi all right
you still there are you still there okay
don't like that what's back okay was it
just me or did she see Oh was it just me
or did she seem really big hi test of
our emergency broadcast system I think I
should probably get out of bed now oh
okay well I didn't like that anyway it
was creeping me out - I'm glad we're on
the same pic scuse my spit hi teddy
oh hey oh well he's murdered well better
you than me buddy I'd rather be here and
not dead then over there and probably
definitely dead okay
are you what the [ __ ] okay [ __ ] off
hi you're good okay is that it at the
end of it
really oh god that doesn't sound good
huh
is someone playing with my brain wha oh
good oh okay
hi love the change that's way better
ah [ __ ] I got to be careful all
goddamnit that - what happened to Teddy
you okay don't look so good
so all in the closets open oh god no I
don't like I [ __ ] you I saw no I did big
no no on that one how about big negatory
on that oh don't you come over my bed oh
I will catch you come into my back okay
oh good all done then great well man so
weird taking off my headset being in my
room just standing around that was cool
I gotta admit that was really cool so
hope you guys enjoyed that if you know
of other horror games that I can play
for the oculus vivre whatever five there
go five and let me know in the comments
below and let me know what you thought
of this one thanks again everybody for
watching then as always don't see you in
the next video bye bye
Oh